julien assange va-t-il trouver l'asile
politique en france une proposition a
portées par une ancienne députée à l'om
sera a débattu aujourd'hui à l'assemblée
un texte soutenu par une soixantaine de
députés de la majorité et de
l'opposition dans les candidats à la
présidentielle jean-luc mélenchon et
fabien roussel on le rappelle le
fondateur de wikileaks et de tenues au
royaume uni depuis 2019 il encourt
jusqu'à
175 ans de prison aux états unis un pays
qui réclame son extradition
le point au palais bourbon avec à notre
reportage katia technique
cette proposition de résolution sera
examinée dans l'après midi à l'assemblée
nationale dans le cadre de la niche
parlementaire du groupe liberté
territoire la députée de jennyfer de
temmerman qui a animé une conférence de
presse le 1er février a présenté ce
projet de résolution il est soutenu par
les députés de l'opposition mais aussi
et c'est assez inédit de la majorité une
soixantaine en tout on retrouve les
soutiens de l'onda du lanceur d' alerte
comme les insoumis et des communistes
mais il ya également des députés en
marche comme jean michel clément ou
pierre alain graf ans jennifer de
temmerman a expliqué lors de la
conférence de presse que cette demande
allait dans le droit fil de la nouvelle
loi protégeant les lanceurs d'alert
qu'il n'y avait pas de raison que la
majorité refuse on l'écoutent je suis
optimiste parce que de toute façon
quelle que soit l'issue du vote ça sera
déjà une grande victoire parce que à la
tribune de l'hémicycle de l'assemblée
nationale
aujourd'hui on va parler de juillet à 16
h et chaque groupe devra se positionner
la question est que la france se
joignent à un mouvement qui existe déjà
on a eu des initiatives en italie on a
de très nombreux parlementaires
allemands qui sont sur le sujet
également l'objectif est tout l'enjeu en
réalité de cette résolution c'est de
porter la question au niveau européen
pour qu'on puisse au niveau européen
définir un statut de réfugié politique
pour les lanceurs d'alert et mettre en
place peut-être un système de parrainage
par des parlementaires de différents
assemblée européenne pour pouvoir
justement trouver une solution à des cas
comme celui de julian assange qui n'en
trouvent pas parce qu'en réalité dans
l'état actuel de droits sans convention
commune on se retrouve dans des
situations de blocage comme celle de
julian assange
en 2020 les avocats de julian assange
avait déjà demandé l'asile auprès de la
france mais cela n'avait pas eu d'effet
auprès du gouvernement le fondateur de
wikileaks est accusé d'avoir fait fuiter
des milliers de documents secrets de
l'armée américaine durant la guerre en
afghanistan et en irak et c'est une saga
judiciaire très éprouvante dans laquelle
est englué julian assange alors que les
états unis demandent son extradition
lors d'une première audience les juges
britanniques l'avait refusé estimant
qu'il y avait un risque suicidaire chez
lanceur d' alerte les américains avaient
fait appel mais cette fois ci les juges
anglais leur avait été favorable
estimant que les états unis avaient
donné des gages de bien-être du lanceur
dallaire cela peut sembler irréaliste
dernier rebondissement dans la sphère
julian assange le fondateur de wikileaks
est il finalement autorisé par la
justice britannique à faire appel de son
extradition aux états unis